I really want to see the new toilet
we'll be by myself it was so bad I know
right the Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn
Part 1 BrahMos there now we're gonna
talk about the movie because I had the
pleasure saying it which is interesting
you may think that I go into these
movies going alright I'm gonna shred
this movie apart which I know that's
what you guys want to see but every time
I'm going to one of these movies I'm
always like alright this might be the
movie that changes my mind I will go in
there with an open mind and every time
I'm disappointed it was so bad alright
so you knew these two teenage twerps
we're gonna get married in this movie
but it happens like really fast like
right at the beginning of the movies
like alright sweet they're getting
married they'll build up or anything
like that just kind of happens which is
interesting because the wedding takes
place in the daytime in fact most the
time you see vampires in this movie
they're out in the daylight listen the
whole point of the thing like oh yeah
they can't be out in the daylight or
else they twinkle and sparkle and
everyone hates that well apparently they
don't do that anymore after the entire
stock is just absurdly inconsistent but
in any case after that they go down on
their honeymoon or whatever and now
they're gonna break the bed which every
girl is looking forward to that part
which at least Jacob addressed what I
was thinking I was like aren't you made
of stone or something are you just gonna
crush her and kill her ever had a
six-foot-tall piece of stone lay on a
human body yeah it's probably gonna die
but now he just breaks the bed but after
that he totally bait and switch
attorneys like ah I bruised your arm we
can't do that anymore yeah she walks out
of there with a couple of bruises which
leads me to think a couple things one
you douchebag oh yeah we're gonna live
happily ever after Oh woohoo ain't going
to touch me anymore no more sex Wow
seriously can we annul this in the
course of their 14 day long honeymoon
they're living like they've been married
for 14 years and two if all you got were
a couple of bruises here you go that was
not real sex which these are our
scenarios either Edward is a big stone
vampire in bellos up for a little sack
of flesh human in which case yeah he'll
probably destroy her or Bella and Edward
are both stone vampires and they sound
like this I don't know maybe he's like
one of those slow and sweet kind of guys
so it's like yes ladies this is the
reality that your brain should not let
you accept it is this stupid it does not
make sense honestly speaking his junk
has to feel like one of those you know
when your grandma would grind up the
spice or something in that weird stone
ball and that thing that would grind it
that's God
what it's like yeah sorry Twihards
reality sucks but that is the reality
so after Edward Cullen goes all Munk on
her and doesn't touch her and they play
chess on their honeymoon or some weird
[ __ ] like that she gets Prager z-- and
now it's a big deal cuz his babies
growing really fast inside her and then
she looks all like gross and skinny I'm
not sure if she looked like Wendy the
hooker from Breaking Bad Hugh Hefner
skeleton or bad murder from Willow with
AIDS in any case it is a pretty good job
at making her look gross and skinny so
props to them and you see Jacob really
shine in this one cuz you know the pack
leaders like alright let's rip apart a
baby or Bella or whoever then jacob
stands up to him with his psychic waves
you know they start reading each other's
minds and whatnot he's like no I do not
take orders from you and he backs the
leader of the pack down like he really
gets in his face and he's like nah screw
you dude then he runs off well seriously
you back down the pack leader everyone
knows if you're gonna do that kill it
off with a hit beat his ass you don't
talk [ __ ] and then run away anyone who
talks [ __ ] like that and then runs away
is an internet troll Jacob is an
internet troll
I really don't like their acting either
they're not good actors Lautner still
makes that same face you can tell them
anything it's like oh hey Taylor Lautner
Bella's gonna die he makes this face or
hey dude you won the lottery you have 19
billion dollars you can buy a hundred
really stupid useless Bella's he makes
this face he's never excited he's never
happy
he just is Taylor Lautner the one
character I actually do like I'll give
the movie this is the brawny paper towel
man you know her dad I mean he's in 1%
of the movie so it doesn't really matter
but the point is him as an actor he's
the best part and had a point in the
movie Edward was like alright I'm gonna
level with you you don't know everything
about me I have killed people you know
back when I was first a vampire no [ __ ]
you know when a dude says hey I'm a
vampire the first thought that should go
through the girl's head is way that
means at one point in your life you were
a murderer right
yeah not Bella's no and he feels bad cuz
he was like I killed criminals I'm a bad
person
dude Bill Compton dripped dried the old
creepy uncle and threw him off of a
cliff into a river
Bella go down to Baum Tom trade up for a
real man or vampire and then when
they're out the Cullen household dealing
with the teen pregnancy and whatnot
Edwards like oh I could read her
thoughts she's like you know she's like
you you Wow
we get another really absurdly boring
chick that thank you life we couldn't
deal with the world without another one
of those running around and yes the part
that we all heard about Jacob sees the
baby
baby and falls in love if the 45 year
old tweye mom standing in line for New
Moon to see 17 year old boys with their
shirts off didn't lock down to
paedophile vibe from this series that
certainly did what we take away from
this movie is that there's nothing to
get your mind off of an 18 year old girl
like an 18 minute old baby I didn't
write the movie and it's just that's in
the movie I'll tell you what that guy's
going to go for babysitter of the year
right there Edward and Bella are gonna
be like uh I gotta go to the grocery
store he's gonna be like oh yeah I'll
watch the kid I'll watch the kids this
is soundproof house so the neighbors
can't hear awesome I'll babysit the kid
creepy bastard so is this movie good Oh
in the course of this entire movie
here's what happens two idiots get
married on their honeymoon they play a
lot of chess another boring [ __ ] and
then a baby that's it that's what we got
it's a two-hour epic of an episode of
secret life of a teenager
it hasn't changed at all I'm gonna give
it its own rating the movie is nothing
yeah don't adjust your monitors this is
what it is a big black screen of nothing
it's not good it's not [ __ ] it is
black screen of nothing that's all I'm
prepared to give it however if you get
pulled into Twilight somehow when the
big stone vampire is laying on the poor
girl about to crush ER in the auditorium
out loud just say skin on skin
let love begin you do that you have a
commitment to comedy that I admire
because that is comedy the best part is
it's almost over I feel like Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows part-2
Reese crawling is I God we're almost
there Twilight fans are going to defend
this movie to their death fact remains
it's just still not good except for
brawny paper towel man it's probably the
mustache in any case if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more